il ya quelque chose qui m'échappe
comment ça se fait que vous soyez encore
en vie j'ai l'impression que tu as fait
une belle chute à commettre convoi dans
le ciel en ce moment passe au dessus de
la terre environ tous les six ans et
ouvre une porte et quand elle s'ouvre
il en sort un visiteur du nouvel
accident à peine le poète guerrier dans
sa version science fiction
l'homme l'espace cours
pour se battre pour toi ju jitsu et
lutte
il n'obtient pas ce qu'il veut il reste
ici et il anéantit tout c'est ça la
règle imposée par brax à ce qu'il
affronte
vous avez tous été choisis
pour être des combattants je lui fis
dessus
mais tant que vous mourrez avec courage
personnes dont on ne saurait tout
[Musique]
il est cinglé comment
mais rien leurs yeux à tous et à bangui
[Musique]
je sais volet moi aussi